[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS LEARY: Hello, everybody.
I'm Chris Leary.
I'm a compiler
engineer at Google.
And I'm here today to tell you
that we can compile TensorFlow,
which is super exciting.
And we have documentation about
how you can compile TensorFlow.
And we have open
source documentation
about the open source
compiler that you can compile
open source TensorFlow with.
So as the ancient
proverb says, "It
takes a village to
raise a compiler."
And many people
have been involved
in the development of XLA.
I'm up here speaking about XLA.
But we've had a lot
of contributions.
And we look forward to a lot
more community involvement
and community contributions now
that it's in the open source.
So I wanted to start off
by talking about some
of the key strengths
of TensorFlow.
It's flexible, it's expressive,
and it's extensible.
And we've heard about
some of those attributes
in the keynote.
So how is this
accomplished in TensorFlow?
The flexibility is due in part
to its interpreted nature.
It's in the name, TensorFlow.
It uses this data flow
programming model.
So what the program does,
you hand it a graph,
it finds a node that's ready
to execute, it grabs it,
it runs it, and then a bunch
more nodes become ready.
And then it goes and grabs
those nodes and executes them.
So that's the interpreter loop
at the heart of TensorFlow.
It's dynamic.
And this is owed in part
to its Pythonic heritage.
You get to use your
full expressiveness
when you define your graph.
And you're not constrained by
some external entity that tells
you what you can
and cannot express.
And it's stateful.
So you get to program
using variables
like you're used to programming
in other environments.
And it's "Black-Box" modular.
So you can come up with
a new dataflow operation
and plug it into TensorFlow
that the original TensorFlow
designers had never
even thought of.
So the question is how, do
we take all those strengths
and add more speed?
So this is a tank
with jet engines
bolted on the top of it.
I thought that
really exemplified
what we're going for with
this kind of approach.
So the way that
we accomplish this
is with just-in-time
compilation via XLA,
which stands for
Accelerated Linear Algebra.
And this is compiler
infrastructure
that we've developed, so that
you can take a TensorFlow
graph in and spit out optimized
and specialized assembly
for that graph.
And to show you how
this works, we're
going to start with a
shell, as programmers love.
So if we start
this video, you'll
see the TensorFlow shell,
as you can build and run
in open source.
And we're passing it a flag
to say, spit out the XLA
assembly that's produced.
So we're piecing in a
very simple expression.
So we're actually just taking
four floating point numbers
and multiplying them.
And we're putting
this explicitly
onto the XLA CPU device.
So the compiler is exposed
as a device in one mode
inside of TensorFlow.
So when we press Enter on
this expression and pause,
then we'll actually see just a
couple of assembly instructions
get emitted.
And some people in the audience
are like, oh, of course,
I know that assembly.
But the point of
this assembly is
there are no loops,
because we knew
that there were exactly
four elements that you're
going to multiply in the graph.
So it actually emitted
the one instruction
that you need in this
Vector Extended Architecture
to implement that expression
on that CPU device.
So optimized and
specialized for the graph
that you fed in with your
TensorFlow expression.
And if we continue
on, we'll also
see that we can place that same
expression onto a GPU device
and compile some GPU assembly
code on the XLA_GPU device that
corresponds to what we
generated on the CPU side.
So as we scroll up,
the GPU assembly
has a little bit
more boilerplate,
because it's launching
multiple threads,
and threads have to
figure out what to do.
But this number
4 here is saying,
I am launching four GPU threads.
And I am specialized
for the fact
that that is the
exact expression
that you typed into TensorFlow.
So this shows that we understand
what expression you give us
at runtime in the
TensorFlow graph
and then compile based
on it for maximum speed.
So if we switch back
to the presentation.
Thank you.
So we see that XLA
for CPU and GPU
works in standard
TensorFlow shell,
as you would use it
in a day to day basis.
So the missing ingredient
to all this is you.
We need you to turn it on.
So as you go and
build TensorFlow,
we really encourage
you to turn this
on, see how it performs for your
use case, file GitHub issues,
and tell us how you
think compilation
could benefit the way
that you use TensorFlow.
We really need more
involvement from the community
to understand where
to prioritize efforts,
because there's a lot of things
you could do with compilation.
There's a lot of potential
avenues you can go down.
So I've said
just-in-time compiler.
So what's this just-in-time
stuff all about?
The essence of just-in-time is
that the program to be compiled
is built at runtime.
So when I type in a TensorFlow
expression and press Enter,
I don't want to sit there at the
command line for a few minutes
while you figure out
how to compile it.
So we need to have low
overhead compilation.
In the blink of an eye, the
assembly has to be generated.
And another aspect of it
is that in ML research,
you don't want to say
what your batch size is
at the very beginning of time.
You want to be able to
say the batch size right
when you figure out
what you want it to be.
So variables can bind
very late in the process.
You could say your batch
size at the very last second.
And because it's a JIT compiler,
it will compile it at the point
that it's defined.
So you get to prototype with
the normal freedom of TensorFlow
development is the gist of
this just-in-time compilation.
So if we look at the
TensorFlow level block diagram,
we have the existing
TensorFlow core.
And Todd is going to be
talking about this in more
detail in his next talk.
But XLA slots into the
TensorFlow ecosystem
here on the bottom right,
where we have some auto JIT
capabilities, where we'll
find clusters to JIT
for you or you can place things
explicitly on devices, as we
showed in that demo video.
So what we think we've
developed with XLA
is a set of
complementary attributes.
So the flexibility that we
get through interpretation,
we get the optimization
benefits of compilation
on the flip side.
The dynamism that lets you
write very expressive programs,
because we find out all of these
dimensions at the last second
and then specialize for
them, we get the benefits
of having the static
information about all the bounds
of the tensors in your graph.
We use pure semantics to
make it easier to compile.
So TensorFlow
actually handles all
of the external
variable rebindings
after the compiled
executable is run,
which makes a smaller
surface area for compilation
and makes it easier to target,
say, new exotic devices.
And you're able to build up
many of the TensorFlow core
operations from these primitives
that we know how to compile.
So you get the
optimization benefits
of all of the things
on the right-hand side,
and you get to think and write
in the traditional way that's
reflected on the left-hand side.
So what has us excited
about this whole approach?
Server-side speed ups, for one.
So through this JIT
compilation and specialization
that we've talked about, we
see model-shaped benchmark wins
of up to 60%.
So those are models
as you would run
in the data center and
model-looking microbenchmarks
roughly in that speed up range.
And for one extreme
in-house example,
we saw SyntaxNet get
latency reductions
from around 200 microseconds
to 5 microseconds.
And the reason for
this was SyntaxNet
had a lot of little
operations in the graph,
so the interpreter has to go
grab each little operation.
And that process of going and
grabbing the little operations
and running them incurs
some latency overhead.
And by compiling,
you're actually
able to eliminate all that
latency overhead away.
Another thing that
has us excited
are mobile footprint reductions.
So with our ahead-of-time
compilation--
we talked about
just-in-time compilation,
but you can also go
through a build process
to turn models into executables
if you want to do that upfront.
So this is just an
executable like you
would run on the
command line, and it's
able to eliminate much
of the TensorFlow runtime
and really reduce
the binary size.
And this lets you also
cross-compile these models
for ARM, PowerPC, and
x86 CPU platforms.
So one example that
we have in-house was
an LSTM model for mobile was
able to go from 2.6 megabytes
to less than 600
kilobytes, which
was a 4x reduction in
the deployment footprint.
The general thing that has us
excited about this approach
is that analyzing a whole
graph, a whole program
is made easy by this
compiler infrastructure.
So we have this thing called
the High-Level Optimizer that's
able to look at a linear
algebra level graph
and create a reusable toolkit
of global optimizations
to work on it.
So even though you compile for
different platforms, CPU, GPU,
and other exotic devices,
we've parameterized
out the things that
are specific to a given
platform at this high-level
optimization toolkit level.
And so you're able
to mix and match
the platform-agnostic and
the target-specific pieces,
so that if there's some
optimization that really
benefits, say, GPUs, you're able
to use that for targeting GPUs,
but you're able to use the
general set of optimizations
in the toolkit for targeting
all the other platforms.
So there are caveats here.
It's experimental.
It's still early days.
Not all TensorFlow
operations compile.
And some of this is because very
dynamic operations, that it's
very difficult to
describe the type for,
won't compile by design.
So for example, dynamic stitch
has a very difficult type
to define for its operations.
So that is not something that
XLA supports and it may never
support it.
The performance is
improving on a daily basis.
So not everything is faster.
And we haven't been able
to devote equal time to all
the platforms that we support.
But with the community's
involvement and prioritization,
we believe that we
could do much more.
So it's open source.
So really, we want you
to try it out, file bugs,
and let us know how
this compilation could
benefit your workload.
So to recap, to go over the
benefits of compilation,
we're able to specialize
the code for the computation
that you handed to the compiler.
So we're able to eliminate
operation dispatch overhead.
We're able to fuse
operations together.
So normally, if you take
one operation at a time,
you'll pull in all the data
from memory, operate on it,
push it back out to memory, and
the next operation will come,
pull it back in from
memory, operate on it,
and spit it back out.
But when you have a
compiler in the mix,
you're actually able to pull
all the memory in one time,
operate on it with
all the operations
that you want to do at
a time, and then flush
it back out to memory.
So this is called fusion.
So we're able to avoid
these expensive round
trips to memory, which
can benefit power
on mobile platforms as well.
We're able to perform precise
and global buffer analysis.
So really, this means, because
we can look at the whole graph
and how all of the tensors
are flowing between all
the operations, we're able to
make compile time trade-offs
between memory usage and speed.
So you might have additional
concurrency that comes,
but it might be at the
cost of additional memory.
So if you were
memory constrained,
you may want to reduce
the peak memory usage.
And we're able to, in
the code generator,
unroll and vectorize, which
are some key optimizations
for today's modern platforms,
via these known dimensions
that we get.
So we know that the tensor
bound for batch size
is a particular value.
And by specializing
for it, we're
able to unlock a whole
category of optimizations
that modern CPUs and
GPUs and other platforms
are designed to run
most effectively.
And as we noted, you get
much smaller executables
out the back, because you
generate exactly what you
need for this specific graph.
So how does this
work under the hood?
Fundamentally, an
XLA program is a set
of static, decomposed
TensorFlow operations.
So they're math-looking
primitive operations
that you compose to
make macro operations.
So this is able to support
many neural net definitions
that we've seen
in the wild today.
So this is a classic
TensorFlow example.
You may have seen
this graph before.
So MatMul and Add, I
know those from math.
Relu is just a
fancy way of saying
max of zero and some value.
But then softmax, that's
kind of interesting one.
That one's not like
the other ones.
So softmax is implemented,
hand-coded in C++ in vanilla
TensorFlow today.
And the question is, why
can't we compose softmax out
of the other
TensorFlow operations
if they support the definition?
And one of the
answers that we hear
is because people don't
want to pay a performance
penalty for doing that.
But what if operation
composition had the performance
of the hand-coded C++?
So if you look at the kind of
stuff that softmax has inside,
it has dots and adds
and reduces and EXPs.
These are all
math-like operations.
And actually, what
the TensorFlow to XLA
bridge, that Todd
will talk about, does
is this built in
operation decomposition,
taking the macro
operation and emitting
several micro operations that we
know how to compile out of it.
So with the primitive
operation composition,
we're still able to generate
the fused and optimized
composite kernel, like you
would have written by hand.
So note that this is all
expressible in TensorFlow.
All those operations that we
showed in the softmax slide
are all primitive
TensorFlow operations,
but XLA removes the
performance concern
of composing these TensorFlow
operations together.
So we're also able to avoid
combinatorial explosions
of custom operation fusions.
For example, we see this
a lot in ML research
with LSTM cells, where
you would technically
have to specialize for every
macro operation, for every set
of primitives inside
the macro operation,
for every dimension
size, for every backend,
CPU, GPU, different
platforms, for every device
within that platform.
But the JIT is able
to look at what you've
provided to it in the graph,
fuse it in a dynamic way,
and then produce the optimized
assembly for the platform
that you're running on.
We've also tried to make
it a minimal surface area,
so that exotic devices
can slot into this XLA
set of primitives.
So if you have a LLVM
pipeline and a runtime plug-in
that we call
StreamExecutor, then you
can actually slot into XLA
today as a potential option,
because the CPU
and GPU back ends
are effectively using
these two throughout
So we think that XLA is useful
throughout the development
lifecycle.
So you get to use
JIT compilation
when you're prototyping.
You get to use compilation
caching as you scale.
So when people request
things from the server,
you're not compiling every time.
You're hitting in a compilation
cache that says, ah, here's
the specialized and
optimized assembly code.
And you're able to use
ahead-of-time compilation
for mobile and embedded devices,
and for latency minimization
on those platforms.
So you get to
control and observe
static properties
of the program.
Especially on mobile
and embedded devices,
this can be important,
for example,
for reducing peak memory usage.
And so now I'm going
to turn it over
to Todd, who works on XLA as
a member of the Google Brain
team, to deep dive on XLA
in the TensorFlow ecosystem.
So Todd?
TODD WANG: Thanks, Chris.
Let's see.
Oh, so maybe-- well,
I'm an engineer, right?
So like when Zach had
mentioned to me that, oh,
would you be willing to
present some of the work
that you've been working on
with a bunch of other people,
I said, yeah, sure.
But I always felt like
in the back of my mind
whether there would
be some fear of his
that maybe I'd come up here
to show this one slide.
This is the
documentation for how
TensorFlow integrates with XLA.
It'd be like, well,
just read the slide.
Like, we'll go along
with it together.
But no, no, I'm not
going to do that.
But I want to take
this opportunity
to introduce this
symbol here, right?
So what is this symbol?
So everyone from
the '90s remembers
that this symbol meant
my website isn't really
working, right?
And so what's the
significance here?
Well, there's a reason why we
sort of call it experimental.
And on some of
the documentation,
we sort of mentioned
it like this, right?
And it's not because we
don't really believe in it.
In fact, it's the opposite.
We think that the approach
is actually really strong.
And we think that the
challenges that we face
are sort of surmountable.
The results that we're
getting, the early results,
are really good, but we're
definitely not done yet.
And so that's why I wanted to
present it to you guys now.
And so I'm going
to phrase this talk
in terms of the
actual open source
directories for the code.
There's four
directories down here.
And I'm going to
go through each one
to describe what's
actually inside of them.
And so the first one is XLA.
And so unsurprisingly, this
is sort of the compiler
that Chris was
just talking about.
As a refresher or maybe
sort of to describe it
at another level of
detail, right, like,
here's XLA in one picture, OK?
And so this is generally
how compilers work, right?
When you talk to
compiler people,
it's like, well, you've got some
representations for the program
that you want.
And in the end, you want
to generate machine code.
That's what the thing does.
And in the middle,
it's like, you
go through these phases of,
like, rewriting the graphs
or, like, lowering the graphs,
different representations.
But at the end of the
day, that's kind of it.
And so on the left here,
we have the XLA graph.
And what this is
composed of, the nodes
are linear algebra
operations and the edges
are sort of the flow
of data, like tensors,
through these operations.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
We lower that to LLVM
IR in the middle here.
Now, LLVM is an open
source compiler toolkit
sort of framework
that's pretty popular.
IR's just an abbreviation
for its intermediate
representation.
So we've basically
lowered the representation
from sort of linear
algebra type stuff
to kind of assembly
type stuff, you know,
general assembly stuff.
And so LLVM then
takes that and does
co-generation, where we
co-generate for actual machine
platforms.
The examples I've given
here, there is x86,
so that supports, like,
servers or your workstations,
ARM, right, for
your mobile phones,
or even, like, PTX,
so this is for GPUs.
So we have a sort
of pretty wide range
of support for the
actual platforms
that we can run this code on.
And so the takeaway,
the thing you
want to remember
from this picture
is that, like, it's
just a compiler,
it's sort of like taking
things from one representation
and putting it down to another.
In our context,
the important thing
is that as long as we can
get things into an XLA graph,
then out pops
machine code for us.
So the next directory
under this compiler
subdirectory is TF to XLA.
And these, literally,
by the way,
are the real directory
names, right?
We're not trying to
hide anything here.
And
So TF to XLA, sort
of unsurprisingly,
it's the stuff that turns
TensorFlow into XLA.
And so similar to that
previous picture for XLA,
here's one picture that sort of
describes what TensorFlow is.
And so on the left, we've got
all the different programming
languages that people can use to
build their TensorFlow program,
right?
And Python is sort of
like the most widely
used, probably, right now,
but there's many others
that we do support.
And what you're
doing when you build
that program is that you're
constructing this graph,
the TensorFlow graph.
And this is the graph
of all your operations
and all of the tensors
flowing through them, OK?
And then we take that graph,
and as Rajat mentioned,
we have a C++ runtime that
actually executes this.
And so there's two
components here.
One is called the executor
and the other is the kernels.
So the job of the executor
is to actually walk
through this graph, and
when it hits each node,
it looks up in the kernels and
finds the appropriate kernel
and actually runs it.
And so as an example, I've
labeled two of the graph nodes
here, like, add and softmax.
Add is just adding two things.
And softmax, well, Chris
just described that.
And so for add,
you think about it,
like, the executor's
going to hit
this add node and need to add
the two inputs that come in.
And so it does that by
looking up inside the kernels,
and finding the C++ fast
implementation for it
for the device that you're
on, and then actually performs
the addition.
Similar for softmax.
We hit the softmax node.
We look up in the kernel.
This one happens to be a
little bit more complicated.
It's not just a simple one
arithmetic operation type
thing.
But still, it looks
it up, runs it.
And so that's basically how
TensorFlow kind of works today.
This is without XLA.
So the next slide
is going to show
sort of how we take
TensorFlow and turn this
into an XLA program.
And this one may be-- it's kind
of a lot of stuff going on,
so I'll walk it through.
On the left, we've got
the TensorFlow graph.
This is that same
thing I just showed.
And it has the add and
softmax labels, OK?
On the right, what
we're trying to generate
is we're trying to
generate that XLA graph.
Remember from that
first slide about,
well, as long as
we can get things
into this representation,
then XLA's
going to take care
of all the rest.
It's going to compile the
thing down to machine code.
And so the way we do that, we
have a local executor, which
is basically the
same thing that we
had for the normal
TensorFlow runtime,
but we swapped out the kernels.
So remember, in the
previous picture,
this was an orange box.
Oh, by the way, so orange
means sort of TensorFlow
to keep with the theme and
everything, and blue means
XLA in all my slides.
So we swapped out
that orange box,
right, with the kernels,
the TensorFlow kernels,
and we swapped in the XLA ones.
And the job of these kernels,
instead of actually executing
the operation, it's going to
be to create this graph, right?
To take the TensorFlow graph
and turn it into the XLA graph.
And so an example here for
add, well, we hit the add node
and we say, OK, we
need to do something.
We look up the
kernel and it says,
great, I know how to transform
the TensorFlow add into the XLA
add.
In this particular example,
it's sort of one to one.
This was a really simple case.
So Chris mentioned softmax,
how it's sort of this more
composite operation, right?
It's built up of
a bunch of stuff
inside, like dot
and exponentiation
and stuff like that.
And so this graph
here is showing
that softmax and the TensorFlow
graph is just one op.
And we look up the
translation kernel
and we turn that into
multiple ops in the XLA graph.
And that's basically all
there is to it, right?
This is how we transform
TensorFlow graphs into XLA.
We have a link
here that describes
where all the kernels
are that actually
perform this translation.
And here's the first
point where we're
going to see this
awesome men at work.
I kind of wish it was a
animated GIF, you know?
Because that'd be
more to the point.
But this men at work, basically,
the kernels that we have,
they're not all there, right?
Like, we haven't implemented
every TensorFlow op.
And this is a place
where for some of them,
they're actually
quite difficult.
And that's the reason we
haven't implemented them.
And maybe, as Chris
was mentioning,
some operations really just
don't translate that well,
because of their
very dynamic nature.
For other ones, we just haven't
gotten around to it, really.
And so this is a place where
actually community support
would be really useful.
OK, so we've sort of
covered what XLA is
and we've covered how we
translate TensorFlow into XLA.
So the next two
points are going to be
about how we actually
use this cool compiler
inside TensorFlow.
And the first thing
we're going to talk about
is JIT, which is, like, the
just-in-time compilation.
And so in the theme of, like,
sort of graph transformations,
I'm going to describe JIT
as sort of this graph, how
the graph changes.
And so on the left, we have
a normal TensorFlow graph.
And in this red trapezoid,
we've identified three nodes.
And these three nodes
are going to be sort
of able to be compiled by XLA.
The other nodes in the graph are
not, for the purposes of this,
going to be compiled by XLA.
And there's many
reasons for that.
We said, sometimes operations
just aren't implemented.
Or other times we've chosen
the clustering that just
happens not to cluster them in.
And so this example, we've
chosen these particular
or these three nodes.
On the right, we see that
we've taken the graph
and we've rewritten it, so that
the same nodes outside of it
are still there,
but on the inside,
we've taken that
cluster or that subgraph
and put it inside this
sort of pink bubble, OK?
And now when you think
about how TensorFlow,
like, the runtime works, it's
working exactly the same.
It's going off of
this right-hand graph,
where it's going
to visit each node,
and it's going to look up
the kernel for the operation
that it represents, and
it's going execute it.
When it hits this
pink bubble, that's
where some of the special
stuff happens, right?
We have inside of it the
notion that this subgraph still
exists.
And we're going to compile that.
We're going to transform that
graph into the XLA graph,
and transform that into
actual machine code,
and then execute that.
This is also where that
caching occurs, right,
where if you happen to hit
that same subgraph again,
so if you run the same
graph multiple times,
or within your program even, if
you have the same subgraph that
shows up multiple
times, we're not
going to pay the cost of
compilation multiple times.
We're going to just compile
that once and execute it
over and over again.
So in this picture,
we're going to show
some of the more
standard sort of ways
that you show up
in these graphs.
Like, the previous one
is kind of simplified.
Now, this one's obviously
also very simplified,
but the main point here
that we're trying to show
is that a single
TensorFlow graph
can have multiple such
clusters show up, right?
And in this example, we've
got two of them on the left.
We've got this blue
rectangle and we've
got that same sort
of red trapezoid.
So the clustering phase is
going to go and identify
which clusters are
going to be compiled.
And on the right side, we've
done the exact same thing.
We've turned those two things
into their respective little
bubbles.
And when the TensorFlow
executor gets to these nodes,
we're going to compile and
run them with the caching
and everything.
So in this slide, we're
going to talk a little bit
about one of the sort of
challenges that shows up.
You might think, well, that was
sort of pretty straightforward.
So here's a
particular challenge.
I mean, it's not, like,
super difficult or anything,
but it's kind of
non-trivial at scale.
So this particular
one, we're showing
a graph where we picked
a clustering that
happens to be pretty bad Yeah,
in fact, it's bad clustering.
Now, you might want to think
a little bit about, well,
what exactly about
this clustering is bad?
If we happened to pick
this clustering, like,
what would actually go wrong?
And so the problem
is evident sort of
on the right-hand
side, where we've
created a cycle between the
non-JITed nodes and the JITed
nodes.
And the issue here is that
just the execution engine,
it's going to have no way
to determine, like, well,
which one do I run first?
How do I actually
execute this graph?
And so this is
obviously something
that we need to avoid while
we're doing the JIT process.
This particular example, it's
not, like, super difficult,
but I mean, as we
get to larger graphs,
this actually becomes
a little bit more
challenging and non-trivial.
So this is an example, a
flavor of the concrete things
that the JIT level is
actually performing for you.
So in order to turn on
the JIT compilation,
we've got two main
ways right now.
And so I'll walkthrough
through the first one.
That's in this blue
box on the top.
It's called Whole
session, right?
And we've really tried
to make it super simple.
And so what this is, ha,
I say, like, we really
try to make it super
simple and then you've got,
like, this super long.
OK but I mean, the concept
is actually super simple.
Never mind the long,
like, label, right?
Conceptually, what
you're doing is
you've got this
configuration that you're
going to pass into to
run your session, right,
to create your session.
And all you need to do is
set this one flag on it
to say, like, turn on the JIT.
And there you go.
What that's going
to do is it's going
to take your entire
graph, it's going
to determine which
clusters of the graph
can actually be
compiled, and it's
going to go and rewrite
the graph into that.
And then when you
actually execute,
it's going to, like, every
time we hit that node, it's
going to perform that
JIT process for you
and actually compile
down to machine code.
And so the concept here is
that you flip this one flag on
and you get, like,
automatic benefit, right?
Things just get
magically faster for you.
So the second way that we
can actually turn on JIT
compilation.
This one's a little
bit more explicit.
We call it, like,
manually scoped, right?
And the idea here is that
here you take your program,
and instead of just
turning on this one flag,
you explicitly put scopes inside
of your program where you can
manually control exactly what
gets compiled and what doesn't.
And one of the ideas
here is that, well, you
might know due to the particular
model or graph that you have,
that certain areas,
it's going to be
very valuable to compute or to
compile this subgraph, but not
this other one.
And so this is how you
can accomplish that.
You get, like, complete control.
In this particular
example, we've
got, like, this one operation
down here, which is add,
and that's the only thing that's
going to be compiled by XLA.
So I said we wanted to make
this sort of super simple,
but it's not as simple
as we would like, right?
Like, I kind of said, well,
you just turn on this one flag
and it sort of
does all the rest.
Well, ideally, it's
like, why do you have
to turn the flag on at all?
Like, shouldn't it just be,
like, doing this automatically?
And this is the point where
there's a little bit of work
in progress.
Like, we have a lot
of ideas here, right,
like about different
heuristics that you
might want to use in terms
of when to turn the thing on,
what kinds of
clusters to create,
and things of that sort.
And so that's
something that we're
sort of working on right now.
In the interim, there's
sort of like these two ways
that you can sort of try
things out for yourself.
OK, we're, like, zooming
right along here.
OK, so so far, we've
talked about XLA,
how we transformed
TensorFlow into XLA,
and how we do the just-in-time
time compilation, right?
You sort of like flip this
flag and automatically things
should get faster or
subportions of your graph
should get faster.
This last part is
going to be about
ahead-of-time compilation.
And keeping in the
sort of graph motif,
I'm going to describe--
so the one picture
sense of, what does
ahead-of-time compilation
really mean, right?
And so on the left, we start
with that normal TensorFlow
graph.
And unlike the JIT, we
take that entire graph now
and we transform that
into the XLA graph.
Like, remember, for the
JIT, we were taking, like,
subportions of the graph,
where as you're running, like,
if particular operations
couldn't be compiled,
that's fine.
We'll just leave those out,
we'll execute them as normal,
but then we'll compile the stuff
that actually can be compiled.
In this mode, the entire
graph needs to be compilable.
But you get a
benefit out of this.
Because once you transform
the entire thing into XLA,
then at the end, out spits
this binary, like x86 or ARM.
I mean, you can just
run this thing directly
on your mobile phone
or your server.
And so this is a pretty
powerful technique.
The way that we do this
is through something
called tfcompile.
This is a tool that's
written in C++,
which is really sort
of like a wrapper tool,
the same way that, like, a GCC
or, like, a Clang or something.
It kicks off, like, the
entire compiler, all right?
And it's pretty simple,
the way that it works.
The concept is that
on the left side,
you start with your
normal TensorFlow graph
and you give it a configuration
file that tells it
what the feeds and fetches are.
So feeds and fetches
are just like TensorFlow
terminology for what the inputs
are and what the outputs are.
You feed that into this
compiler, this tool,
and out at the other end
pops, like, your binary, like,
machine code for whatever
platform that you want to run
on and a C++ header.
To give you a little
bit more of an idea
of what exactly are
we doing, right?
That C++ header is conceptually
like a function, right?
We've turned that
graph and we've
identified what the
inputs are. identified
with the outputs are.
So we turn that entire
graph into a single function
where the feeds are
the input arguments
and the fetches are
the output arguments.
And so that's pretty
simple, right?
I'm actually pretty excited
about this, because this
is a pretty cool way to
think about things in terms
of not just reducing
binary sizes,
but also, like, different
ways of deployment, right?
We've got this, like, fancy
way to describe machine
learning computations
in TensorFlow, right?
And you can build these
extraordinarily complex
and, like, intricate models.
All of that turns into
this graph for TensorFlow.
And you can feed that entire
graph into this tfcompile.
And out at the other
end pops, like,
a single function that
you can call, right,
with your inputs
and your outputs.
And that's actually pretty cool.
Some of the remaining pieces of
work here, right, that we have.
One of them is that the only
binaries that we currently
support, the only
back end, is for CPU.
And so both for workstations,
like x86, or for mobile,
like ARM but not GPU yet.
And there's no technical reason
why we haven't done this.
It's just we have limited time.
And so we haven't done it yet,
but that's definitely something
that we want to
do moving forward.
Another cool future direction
actually is I've mentioned,
well, the only sort of language
binding that we support right
now is C++.
Or actually, technically,
C as well, I guess.
Either way, you can
call this function
through this header file.
There's no reason
why, conceptually, we
couldn't add a thin
wrapper that allows
you to call this function
now through your programming
language of choice.
Like, basically, everything
supports binding to C
to some extent.
And so you could use,
like, Python and SWIG
or you could use, like, well,
in this example, like, Java
and JNI.
Or if you like Go, right,
you could use Go and cgo.
Like, there's many different
ways where, like, you
could actually simplify
your deployment
story using a compiler.
So the next few slides
are going to talk
a little bit about the
details through exactly
how this tfcompile thing works.
The first part I'm
going to talk about
is, you know, I had a
little configuration
file where we said, what are the
feeds and what are the fetches?
And so this is expressed
in sort of Google protobuf.
So if you're not familiar
with this, the file
itself right now is the text
version of the protobuf.
It looks kind of like JSON.
It's not very
complicated, actually.
So this top part
has, like, two feeds.
And remember, we're identifying
the inputs into the graph,
right?
So in this particular
simple example,
we've got, like, x and y happen
to be our inputs in this graph.
And we tell the compiler
exactly what the shapes are.
This is a good point
to reemphasize, right?
Like, Chris had mentioned
sort of TensorFlow
has this extreme
flexibility, where it really
allows you to do stuff
very easily and quickly.
But for compilers, it's much
better if you can specialize,
right?
That's one of the
benefits that you
get, if you can specialize
based on the exact sizes
that you have.
And so here for
any of the inputs
that come into your graph,
you tell it exactly,
like, here's the exact sizes
that we're going to use.
Similarly, for as the feeds,
we've got the fetch here.
And for the fetch, you
basically just identify
which node or nodes you want
as outputs of the function
that you're going to generate.
In this case, you don't have
to specify the shape anymore.
In fact, you can't, just
because given the input shapes,
we can sort of infer what
the shape is at the output
all the way through the graph.
And so this is
basically the only sort
of piece of
configuration that you're
going to need to actually
run this compiler.
The next step is going
to talk about, well,
how do you actually
invoke the thing, right?
So I've got this
configuration file.
I've got my graph.
How do I kick it off?
And so the example I'm
going to present here
is when you use Bazel.
So basically,
through Bazel, we've
created a Bazel
build macro, which
is just like syntactic sugar
to kick off the whole thing.
We've introduced this one
notion called tf_library
and it's pretty simple.
You're basically just giving
it, like, three main pieces
of information and it's the
ones we've just already talked
about.
The first one is
the graph, right?
You sort of give it the
graph in protobuf form.
The second one is the
feeds and fetches.
This is a configuration file.
That was that thing
that I just showed.
You know, simple, like, here's
the feeds, here's the fetches,
here's the size of the feeds.
And the third thing here is
the C++ class name, right?
And so this is the class name
that will be generated for you
in that C++ header, which
will allow you to invoke
the computation.
Now, one thing to note, I know,
like, in the open source world,
I mean, I experience
this, too, right?
Like, not that many
people use Bazel.
And so if you don't actually use
Bazel, all is not lost, right?
Like the tfcompile
tool is just something
you can run the command line.
And basically, like, these
configuration options
that I just described
are the flags
that you pass into the tool.
And in addition, you
can tell it where
do I want my output
object file and where
do I want my output file to go.
And that's about it.
So we tried to make this
sort of easily integratable
into whatever build
system you have.
Just a note on that,
it's like, this
is another place where
lots of community help
would be great, because
there's, like, an astounding
number of different build
environments that people have,
like Make, CMake.
There's, like, a whole
bunch of these things.
So it should be relatively
simple to actually add
in that integration.
OK, so here it's sort of like
there's a whole bunch of code.
And I know, like, people's
eyes are sort of glazing over
and stuff.
So I'm going to, like, just
try to describe this in sort
of like a straightforward way.
And so what we're
trying to describe here
is, like, the simple way
that you can actually
invoke the computation
that we've just described.
This is C++ code, because that's
sort of the language that we
currently support.
And at the top, you
sort of include,
well, your generated header.
This is the thing that was
automatically generated for you
to invoke the computation.
And on this line, we instantiate
this class, this TestMatMul.
That was the class that's
described, defined inside
of that generated header.
And note, we've got this
MatMul variable now.
So if you look
through the slide,
basically, matmul,
that instance is, like,
what we're going
to use throughout.
The next step is a to set up
the arguments to actually run
this computation.
This particular computation
we're going to assume
is, like, a matrix
multiplication.
And so all of this code is
really just a fancy-- you know,
this is how in C++, you say
that my first argument is going
to be the numbers 1 to 6 and my
second argument's going to be
the numbers 7 to 12.
And then you call this one
thing called matmul.Run.
And basically, that's
invoking whatever computation
you had in your graph.
And at the end, you can
grab the results out
of the matmul object.
And so hopefully this gives
you a sense for, like, kind
of how simple it really is.
You can take whatever
arbitrarily complex model
that you have and boil
it down to a function
that you can just call.
And so to recap, we've
covered sort of the compiler
subdirectory under TensorFlow,
which has XLA, right,
this is the compiler,
c to XLA, which
does the TensorFlow
to XLA transformation,
the JIT, which is
the just-in-time,
and AOT, which is ahead-of-time.
And so now I'm going to
present some results.
So one thing to note
here is that when
Megan was talking
about some of the cool,
you know, the awesome
performance results
that we've had, none of that was
actually including XLA, right?
So the first slide I'm
going to show is on JIT.
And when you use JIT for
different models running
on GPU, what is the speed up?
And so the way to read
this is that each row is
one particular model
that we've run.
And the numbers on the chart
are describing, well, what's
the speed up or slow down?
So in essence, for
each row, we've
run this particular
model two ways.
We've run it once using
just normal TensorFlow.
And we've run it another
time with XLA enabled,
with that JIT flag enabled.
And the JIT flag is
going to compile things
down and hopefully
make things faster.
And so what you're
seeing here is
that basically all of the green
stuff is positive numbers.
And so kind of the whole point
in this slide is, well, faster
is better.
And the collection of models
that we actually have here
are sort of things that
we actually do care about.
It's not just arbitrary things.
The first couple of
examples are for GMT.
That's the neural
machine translation.
So it's one of these
stacked LSTM-type models.
Next down the list, we've got
Inception, AlexNet, like, some
of the image processing models.
One of the reasons
why we see speed ups
here are due to the
things that Chris actually
mentioned, right?
We get this fusion
of operations.
Like, element and
wise operations
get automatically
fused together.
And so if the long pole
basically in your computation
is streaming through
all of the data,
well, that's going
to help a lot, right?
You've got that these
tiny operations,
like, you want to add things,
you want to multiply things,
you can fuse them all together.
Also, there's sort of different
paralyzation and buffer
allocation strategies that
we have that can actually
provide additional speed up.
Another thing we want
to point out here
is that it's not
just for inference
or not just for training.
It's actually for both.
And so here the pink
boxes are highlighting
the training examples
or the models
where we actually ran training.
So both the forward pass
and back [INAUDIBLE].
And this is actually
pretty cool.
One observation, though,
here is that, well, it
seems, at least on this picture,
that lots of the training ones
are sort of lower down
on the list, right?
They're not getting as much
of a performance improvement
or maybe, even in some cases,
maybe a negative performance
improvement.
So negative here means
that we actually are worse.
We're not as good.
And so on the training
side, one reason for this,
it's basically, you know,
training graphs, in general,
are a little bit
more complicated.
You can think about,
like, inference graphs
as only having the forward pass.
But once you add
training, you're
going to have, like, backprop.
You're going to have to
compute the gradients.
And so that makes
the entire graph
larger and more complicated.
And that's one of
the reasons why
sort of like some of the
numbers are a little bit lower
for the training side, but
it's definitely something
that we want to work on.
And so trying to improve all of
these numbers as much as we can
is something that we're
actively working on right now.
So the next slide.
So actually, with
that previous slide,
if you saw that in an
academic paper or something,
you'd be like,
yeah, whatever, man.
I don't believe this guy, right?
Because it's like, it just
looks like too positive.
And so here I've taken a
collection of microbenchmarks.
Oh, another thing to note,
actually, these numbers
are for real.
These numbers are all actually--
I grabbed them, like, yesterday
off of the actual benchmarks
that we've been running,
like, constantly.
And so I just grabbed
a snapshot of whatever
yesterday was and, like,
plopped them onto this chart.
And so here, again, it's
the same graph layout.
The green stuff on the right,
you know, positive numbers.
Those are speed ups.
That's good.
And the red stuff on the
left, negative numbers.
That's kind of bad.
And so we see some
pretty good speed ups.
There's a big, hefty chunk
here where things get up
to as much as 50%.
And down here there's,
like, room to improve.
I talked a little bit
about some of the things
that we might want
to do to improve.
Another thing that we've
noticed down here is that--
you can't read the
font, because it's
tiny-- but then lots
of the models down here
or lots of the microbenchmarks
that we're running
are for sort of
like prefused cells.
So these are things
where we take advantage
of existing compilers or
existing implementations
of fast-fused kernels.
And so when the TensorFlow
op comes in that does that,
TensorFlow by itself
does a really good job,
because it's kicking
off this fast kernel,
but the XLA side doesn't really
do a good job of that right
now.
And so just to be, like, sort
of honest about where we are,
that's kind of where
we are, but we're
trying to improve the thing.
So this slide really
proves to you that I'm not,
like, in marketing or
something like that.
Yeah, I actually got
a C-plus in marketing.
So the previous two
slides were GPU, right?
And so this slide's, like, CPU.
Again, on the JIT, right?
And again, speed ups and
green are supposed to be good.
And slowdowns and red
are supposed to be bad.
And so this is, like, not good.
And so the simple
way to describe this
is that, yeah, we've got the
men at work thing, you know?
I can give you a
little bit more detail
behind that, though, right?
Like, one of the
simple reasons is
because we don't have
unlimited people working on it
and so we have to prioritize.
And we're kind of like
practical people, right?
We kind of thought,
well, I mean,
if you're using TensorFlow and
you want to use this compiler,
then you probably want
to make things faster.
And if you want to make
things faster, then
probably you're using GPUs
use right now already.
And so the first thing
we're going to focus on
is, like, improving
GPU performance,
because you can get, like,
the most benefit out of that.
One of the concrete reasons
why this particular-- many
of these benchmarks
are actually worse
is that currently,
TensorFlow already paralyzes
much of the operations, right?
If you have multiple operations,
they can run in parallel.
This is on top of the within
single op parallelism,
where, let's say,
you have a big matmul
and we do fancy tiling and
stuff to parallelize that as
much as possible.
On the XLA side, we do
have separate back ends
for sequential and
parallel, but we simply
haven't put very
much time into it.
And so there's a lot
of low-hanging fruit
here, actually, where I think we
can improve these numbers quite
easily and quite dramatically.
So this would also
be an area where,
if you're interested, then,
like, there's definitely
in terms of community
involvement,
there's lots of stuff here.
And it's all in open source.
So that would be kind
of a lame sort of slide
to end on in terms
of performance.
But one thing we haven't
really talked about
is smaller binaries, right?
I mentioned, like,
there's many ways that you
can use the compilation.
You can do, like, a
JIT or ahead-of-time.
This is for
ahead-of-time, right?
And the specific thing
we're trying to target here
is that on mobile,
like, binary size
actually makes a big difference.
Like, your users don't want
to sit around and wait for,
like, many, many
megabytes to be downloaded
for your application.
And so using the
compiler, we can actually
get significant sort of
binary size reductions.
The particular example we have
here is for a stacked LSTM.
This particular one
happens to be, like,
three deep and 60 wide.
So you've got LSTM cells sort
of like 60 wide in sequence
and then three deep.
And it's compiled
for Android ARM.
And this is, like,
a real application.
The original binary
size was 2.6 megabytes.
And that breaks down to a 1
megabyte for the TensorFlow
runtime, with only the
ops that we actually need,
and then 1.6 megabytes
for the graph.
And when we compile that down,
we end up with 600 kilobytes,
right?
And so that was what
Chris was talking
about in terms of, like,
a four times reduction.
272 kilobytes of that is code
and 330 kilobytes is weights.
So I'm going to
focus in on that 272.
Because even four times,
that's sort of not enough.
I want to make it bigger, right?
So I want to point out,
this picture down here,
which is sort of like you can't
really read anything on it,
it's basically a tree map
of all of the binary size
usage broken down by
what's actually using it.
And so on this box here, this
is the actual generated code
that we created.
It's only 88 kilobytes.
So the next box that we
have is Eigen. And so this
is 76 kilobytes.
This is a good point
to also mention that,
so you might
wonder, well, what's
Eigen doing in this
picture, right?
Like, Eigen, if you don't
know, is a C++ templated sort
of specialized linear
algebra sort of library.
So it let's you do, like,
matmuls really fast.
Does that sort of tiling and
stuff depending on your sizes.
In XLA, we have the opportunity
to not just implement
all these things
on our own, right?
But if we have good
implementations
that already exist, we can
just take advantage of it.
And so in this
particular case, we've
taken advantage for
single-threaded Eigen
for the matrix
multiplications that
happen inside the LCM cells.
So that takes up 76 kilobytes.
And actually, on the
right, the majority
is taken up by standard
Android libraries.
This is, like, 108 kilobytes.
So this is just a
snapshot of sort
of like the we believe
we can actually
make things much smaller
even if we really wanted to.
But 272 or 600 kilobytes
even is a pretty good start.
It's, like, a four
times reduction already.
And so to summarize,
we've talked
about how so TensorFlow
graphs are compiled via XLA.
We have both just-in-time and
ahead-of-time compilation.
And so they're both pretty cool
and serve different use cases.
And some models,
some real models,
are actually already
faster or smaller.
So it's all really neat.
And oh, yeah, the last thing is
that work in progress, right?
Like, we're continually trying
to improve these things.
Like, all those
benchmark numbers,
we're working on that
on sort of a daily basis
to try to make things better.
And so with that,
that's the talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]